recently had another question someone
want to know if sugar so bad dr. Berg
why is fruit so healthy okay well first
of all I never said the fruit was so
healthy okay and it's not part of a
healthy Kido plan that being said
there's some several things I want to
tell you about the fruit that we consume
now our hybrids which means that over
the years they created these fruits to
be sweeter and sweeter and sweeter Honey
Crisp apple for example has 19 grams of
sugar I mean take a look at a crabapple
it doesn't have 19 grams of sugar so
we're consuming more sugary fruits okay
that's one thing number two
fruits should be seasonal okay if you're
consuming all year-round that's not
really natural some people also don't
differentiate between whole fruit and
fruit juice they say they're the same
but they're not the juice is not not
only without the fiber but without the
nutrients because they pasteurize it
they heat it and that kills a lot of the
enzymes allow the heat sensitive
vitamins so now we have basically pure
sugar okay versus this which has
vitamins and minerals phytonutrients and
fiber so it is true that these fruits
have these nutrients okay which are
protective against DNA damage against
the complications of diseases like
diabetes for example however fruit has a
larger amount of a certain sugar called
fructose okay fructose does not go to
all the cells in the body like glucose
does it only goes to the liver a hundred
percent of it goes to the liver what
does that mean it means that it's not
going to spike your blood sugar as much
okay and if you consume fruit and check
your blood sugars and you go wow it
didn't affect my blood Sugar's it must
be good what you're missing is that all
that fructose is going to liver and the
liver has to deal with it if you do too
much it could lead to insulin resistance
which will raise insulin so if the liver
has to deal with too much fructose it
has to put it somewhere so it converts
it to fat and cholesterol and
triglycerides so my advice is be
the percent of the population that has a
problem with blood sugars and
pre-diabetes I recommend that you stick
with a small amount of berries and not
do fruit I mean if you think about what
is diabetes okay
diabetes is high blood sugar so why
would we want to add fruit to that
that's going to add more sugar to a
condition that is already too high in
sugar anyway thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next video hey if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos